je voudrais vous raconter une petite
anecdote il ya quelques années je suis
allé voir un concert du groupe maroon
five et les places étaient partis super
vite parce que le groupe était déjà
assez connu à l'époque il faisait qu'une
seule date en france et en plus c'était
une petite salle c'était le casino de
paris et le soir du concert quelqu'un
qui avait pas réussi à avoir de place à
temps propose de me racheter la mienne
pour 200 euros
j'avais dû la payer seulement 40 euros
mais pourtant bas j'ai refusé ce qui est
bizarre c'est que si dès le départ cette
place elle avait été à 200 euros bas
jamais je leur ai acheté nord 200 euros
j'aurais trouvé ça trop cher pour ce
concert mais du coup je trouve que cette
place elle vaut pas 200 euros quand il
est question de l'acheter mais elle vaut
plus que 200 euros quand il est question
de la vendre je serais pas un peu crétin
mois
la situation que je viens de vous
décrire les représentatif de ce que les
économistes appellent l'effet de
dotation c'est le fait qu'on attribue
plus de valeur à une chose si on la
possèdent que si on la possèdent pas en
soyons clair à mon anecdote
scientifiquement elle vaut que dalle est
donc déjà c'est juste un cas sur une
personne et puis il ya plein de bonnes
raisons qui peuvent expliquer que j'ai
pas voulu vendre la place même pour 200
euros
je m'étais réjoui à l'avancé d'aller au
concert j'avais fait le déplacement et
c'est dans une anecdote c'est pas de la
science mais rassurez vous il ya des
économistes et des psychologues qui ont
fait des expériences bien contrôlé pour
étudier scientifiquement cet effet de
dotation est une des expériences les
plus intéressantes on la doit notamment
à daniel kahneman dont j'ai déjà parlé
plusieurs fois dans crétin de cerveau
kahneman et ses collaborateurs ont réuni
un groupe de gens et à la moitié d'entre
eux pris au hasard
ils ont donné un mug mais pas aux autres
et ils ont mesuré à quel prix ce qui
avait un mug serait prêt à le vendre
et dans le même temps avec ceux qui n'en
avaient pas ils ont déterminé à quel
prix ils seraient prêts à l'acheter
résultats prix de vente moyen de ceux
qui avaient le mug 5 $ 25 mai prix
d'achat moyen de ceux qui ne l'avaient
pas deux dollars 50 à peu près la moitié
c'est-à-dire qui se passe dans cette
expérience à peu près la même chose que
pour moi avec ma place de concert ce qui
avait le mug lui attribuait plus de
valeur que ceux qui ne l'avaient pas et
là on parle pas d'un objet personnel ou
d'un truc auquel il avait le temps de
s'attacher depuis longtemps on en parle
d'un simple bug convenait de leur donner
ensuite kahneman et ses collaborateurs
ont fait une variante de l'expérience
ils ont utilisé un autre groupe et
d'autres modes comme dans la première
expérience à la moitié des gens ils sont
donnés le mug et leur demander à quel
prix serait prêt à le vendre et à
l'autre moitié ils ont donné le choix
entre recevoir un mug et recevoir
l'argent en variant le montant pour
déterminer à partir de quelle somme
qu'il préférait l'argent au mug
l'estimation moyenne de la valeur du
mode par le premier groupe a été 7
dollars
mais pour le second groupe seulement 3
dollars il faut bien voir ce que ça veut
dire le second groupe si on leur donne
le choix entre cinq dollars et un mug
ils vont prendre 5 dollars alors que le
premier groupe si on leur propose de
racheter le mug pour 5 dollars il vous
refusez pourtant c'est exactement la
même chose
les deux groupes à la fin ils ont le
choix entre repartir en ayant un mug ou
reparti en ayant 5 dollars oui sauf que
le premier groupe on leur avait donné le
mug avant cette expérience elle montre
que l'effet de dotation il est puissant
et instantanée inde et que vous possédez
quelque chose vous lui attribuez plus de
valeur que dix secondes auparavant
alors est ce que c'est vraiment
irrationnelles comme comportement et ben
arty mais pas complètement et pour
comprendre ça on va regarder comment les
économistes analysent le phénomène les
économistes comme camman se sont
demandés comment sur le plan théorique
on pouvait expliquer l'effet de dotation
et l'explication repose sur deux
ingrédients
le premier c'est qu'entre perdre quelque
chose et gagner la même chose la perte
est toujours plus douloureuse que le
gain est agréable c'est ce que les
économistes appellent la version aux
pertes et ça c'est pas absurde 1 comme
comportement c'est même assez rationnel
on va prendre un exemple la surface de
votre logement
imaginons que vous viviez dans mettons
40 mètres carrés et ça vous procure un
certain niveau de satisfaction si je
vous propose 20 mètres carrés en plus
votre satisfaction va augmenter puis
encore 20 mètres carrés de plus elle
augmentera à nouveau mais d'une quantité
un peu moindre par contre si je vous
propose 20 mètres carrés en moins que ce
que vous aviez au départ là vous allez
vraiment perdant satisfaction pour la
plupart des biens la courbe de notre
satisfaction n'est pas proportionnelle à
la quantité qu'on possède
elle croit de moins en moins vite les
mathématiciens discale et convexes avec
une courbe de satisfaction convexe c'est
parfaitement normal que les pertes nous
impacte plus qu'un gain équivalent sauf
que dans la vraie vie on raisonne
rarement de manière absolue comme on
vient de le faire avec la surface d'un
logement
on raisonne de manière relative par
exemple si je vous propose d'acheter ce
meuble pour 5 dollars vous allez vous
demander si vous vous sentirez mieux
après avoir déboursé 5 $ pour la voir
mais vous n'allez pas faire un
raisonnement dans l'absolu un
raisonnement dans l'absolu ça serait un
truc du genre
alors j'ai déjà 7 me gala maison et 1669
euros sur mon compte en banque
est ce que je préfère ça ou bien avoir
1664 euros sur mon compte en banque mais
8 me ben non on raisonne généralement en
relatif
en analysant les gains ou les pertes par
rapport à une situation de référence
c'est ce que les économistes appellent
la dépendance à la référence et comme
référence et bien on prend très souvent
la situation actuelle au final on peut
donc expliquer l'effet de dotation par
la combinaison de ces deux ingrédients
dont on vient de parler
la dépendance à la référence on juge les
choses en relatif et la version aux
pertes
les pertes paraissent toujours plus
douloureuse que les gains équivalent
dans l'expérience de catman celui qui
n'a pas reçu de mugs va se demander quel
plaisir ça va lui apporter d'en avoir un
et celui qui a reçu un mug va prendre ça
comme situation de référence et va se
demander quelle douleur ça va lui causer
de le perdre et c'est pour ça qu'il va
lui attribuer plus de valve
puisqu'on prend souvent comme référence
la situation actuelle l'effet de
dotation et là une conséquence pratique
il pousse au statu quo celui qui a reçu
le mug a pas très envie de le vendre
et celui qui l'a pas reçue à pas très
envie de l'acheter mais ce qui est
rigolo c'est que si dès le départ on
avait donné le mug à l'autre la
situation aurait été la même
il y aura eu statu quo d'ailleurs les
économistes trouvent parfois des
illustrations grandeur nature et un
volontaire de cet effet de statu quo par
exemple dans le new-jersey et en
pennsylvanie dans les années 90 il y
avait une loi obligeant les conducteurs
avoir une police d'assurance fournis par
l'état et avec le choix entre deux
niveaux de protection un niveau pas cher
et un niveau plus cher avec une
protection plus élevées dans le new
jersey par défaut on avait l'assurance
pas cher et il fallait payer pour avoir
l'autre seuls 23% des gens faisaient le
changement par contre en pennsylvanie
c'était le contraire par défaut on avait
la police d'assurance la plus chère et
53 % des gens choisissaient de la
conserver dans les deux cas le choix par
défaut le statu quo paraissait le plus
attractif
alors on imagine assez vite les
possibilités de manipulation commercial
je commence par faire semblant de vous
offrir le bug ou bien avec l'assurance
du coup ça change votre point de
référence ça augmente sa valeur à vos
yeux et ensuite j'aurai moins de
difficultés à vous le faire vraiment
payé autre possibilité de manipulations
offertes par la dépendance à la
référence c'est le fait qu'on va juger
une situation différemment suivant
qu'elle nous est présenté comme un gain
ou comme une perte est un exemple
superbe ce sont les médailles aux jeux
olympiques
regardez cette photo et on peut
retrouver des tas de ce genre le
médaillé de bronze est super content et
aux médaillés d'argent fait la gueule
bah oui il y en a un qui prend comme
référence le fait qu'il aurait pu être
en bas du podium et qui vit sa médaille
de bronze comme un gain et l'autre qui
se dit qu'il aurait pu être champion
olympique et qui vit sa médaille
d'argent comme une perte présenter les
choses comme un gain ou comme une perte
peut modifier les comportements il ya
par exemple une étude qui a été faite
sur la manière de présenter leurs bonus
à des salariés à une partie des gens on
a présenté le bonus comme un gain c'est
la manière traditionnelle si vous
atteignez vos objectifs vous aurez une
prime et à une autre partie on la
présentait comme une perte c'est à dire
que le bonus est distribuée davance à
titre préventif et on vous le reprendra
si les objectifs ne sont pas atteints
et devinez quoi et par les seconds ont
été plus performants que les premiers
après niveau stress au travail je suis
pas sûr de l'apport pour les autres
exemples d'une manière de présenter une
chose comme un gain en comme une perte
qu'est ce que vous préférez une
son salaire de 2 % sachant que
l'inflation et 3% ou bien une diminution
de votre salaire de 1 % sachant qu'il
n'y a pas d'inflation bien sûr que vous
savez pertinemment que c'est la même
chose mais en votre for intérieur vous
trouvez pas quand même que la première
solution est un peu moins douloureuse
alors rassurez vous même les économistes
professionnels se font avoir par ce
genre de manipulation et une expérience
intéressante qui a été fait pour
l'inscription à une conférence
d'économie les participants devaient
payer des frais d'inscription et puis
comme souvent pour faciliter
l'organisation
le prix était moins cher si on
s'inscrivait suffisamment tôt à la
moitié des gens au moment de s'inscrire
sur le site internet
on présentait sa commune réduction
c'est-à-dire prix d'inscription 195
dollars mais réduction de 50 $ si jamais
on s'inscrit avant une certaine date
et puis pour l'autre moitié s'étaient
présentés comme une augmentation prix de
145 dollars mais avec une pénalité de 50
$ si on s'inscrit après une certaine
date est bien dans le premier cas 67 %
des participants seulement se sont
inscrits en avance alors que dans le
deuxième cas 93%
c'est à dire que la menace de
l'augmentation du prix a été bien plus
forte que la promesse de la réduction
et pourtant les deux prix étaient
exactement les mêmes cette idée que la
référence réelles ou perçues joue un
rôle sur nos prises de décision elle a
notamment été évoqué au sujet du
principe de la détention provisoire si
vous êtes en détention provisoire
vous serez peut-être plus enclins soit
plaidé coupable soit essayer de négocier
un compromis
parce que vous verrez ça comme un moyen
de regagner votre liberté alors que si
vous n'êtes pas en détention provisoire
va peut-être que vous vous battrez plus
pour prouver votre innocence
parce que vous verrez ça comme un moyen
de préserver votre liberté c'est à dire
que la détention provisoire en fête
change le point de référence et donc
changer nos comportements
en plus des exemples que j'ai déjà donné
le principe du point de référence va pas
simplement servir à présenter un gain
comme une perte ou vice versa mais aussi
à moduler la valeur à nos yeux d'un gain
ou d'une perte par exemple daniel
kahneman a soumis des sujets à
l'expérience suivante vous acheté dans
un magasin une veste qui coûte 125 $ et
une calculatrice qui coûte 15 dollars et
le caissier sympa vous informe que dans
un autre magasin de l'enseignent située
un peu plus loin il brade la calculette
pour seulement 10 dollars est-ce que
vous fait le déplacement
réponse oui à 68% et un deuxième groupe
même histoire mais cette fois c'est la
veste dont prix est un peu plus bas dans
un autre magasin 120 dollars seulement
est-ce que vous fait le déplacement
réponse oui à seulement 29 % et pourtant
c'est le même problème un regard des
biens dans les deux cas on en a pour 140
dollars au total
et on nous propose de faire un
déplacement pour gagner 5 dollars sauf
que dans le premier cas on juge les 5 $
comparativement au prix de 15 dollars de
la calculatrice et on trouve ça
intéressant alors que dans le second cas
on juge les 5 $ comparativement au prix
de 125 $ de la veste et on se dit que ça
vaut pas le coup
autre exemple pour illustrer ce genre de
phénomène mais avec des pertes cette
fois imaginons vous décidez d'aller voir
une pièce de théâtre et la place coûte
10 euros vous avez acheté le ticket à
l'avance est arrivé à l'entrée du
théâtre vous rendez compte que vous
l'avez perdue est-ce que vous l'a
racheté pour 10 euros ou est ce que vous
laissez tomber l'idée d'aller voir la
pièce est bien dans l'expérience
seulement 46% des gens rachètent le
ticket et comme toujours on a un
deuxième groupe et on le soumet à une
situation légèrement différente
vous décidez d'aller voir une pièce de
théâtre mais vous n'avez pas acheté le
ticket à l'avance est arrivé à l'entrée
du théâtre vous remarqué que vous avez
perdu un billet de 10 euros dans votre
portefeuille
est ce que vous achetez quand même votre
place de théâtre réponse oui à 88% et je
vous laisse vous convaincre que
financièrement parlant il s'agit bien la
même situation
dans les deux cas on a perdu 10 euros et
il s'agit de payer 10 euros pour pouvoir
les voir la pièce de théâtre
sauf que dans le deuxième cas on a
simplement perdu 10 euros alors que dans
le premier cas on juge la perte de 10
euros par rapport à une référence le
prix de notre ticket est donc
psychologiquement on a l'impression que
le prix de la place double je voudrais
finir sur un dernier exemple assez
spectaculaire du rôle de la référence et
qui va me servir de transition avec le
prochain épisode de crétin de cerveau
imaginons vous venait d'attraper un
virus donc
vous dit qu'il est mortel dans 0,1 pour
cent des cas c'est-à-dire un cas sur
1000 heureusement il existe un vaccin
qui peut vous en protéger
combien seriez-vous prêt à mettre pour
acheter des vaccins réponse typique
obtenu 200 dollars autre situation
maintenant vous êtes en bonne santé et
on vous propose de participer à un test
clinique d'un nouveau vaccin
le seul hic c'est qu'il ya un risque de
0,1 pour cent pour que le test se passe
mal et que vous mourriez combien vous
demanderiez en compensation pour
accepter de participer aux tests réponse
typique obtenu dix mille dollars
et pourtant encore une fois les deux
situations sont assez analogues dans les
deux cas il s'agit de mettre une valeur
monétaire sur un risque de 0,1 pour cent
de mourir
sauf que dans le premier cas la
référence c'est qu'on a déjà chopé le
virus alors que dans le deuxième cas la
référence c'est qu'on est en bonne santé
et donc dans le premier cas si on meurt
c'est en quelque sorte par omission
alors que dans le deuxième cas c'est par
action volontaire et du coup
psychologiquement c'est quand même pas
la même chose
est ce que c'est vraiment irrationnel de
se comporter très différemment dans ces
deux situations
je vous laisse vous faire votre opinion
et de toute façon on reviendra sur ces
questions dans le prochain épisode de
crétin de cerveau qui parlera de la
manière dont on évalue les risques
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo comme
toujours n'hésitez pas à la partager si
elle vous a plu pour m'aider à faire
connaître la chaînes vous pouvez
retrouver les actualités de la chaîne
sur facebook et sur twitter
et ceux qui souhaitent peuvent me
soutenir surtout dit merci à bientôt